very significant Powers as we've
demonstrated here actually the penalty
that William Hill will its group are
paying now is two to three times higher
than it was last time we've made it very
clear if things don't improve we will
see higher penalties and if necessary we
will suspend and revoke licenses during
the last year we've suspended the
licenses of four operators who weren't
meeting the standards that we require so
we have the powers what we need to see
is the compliance from The Operators and
I'm pleased to say we are starting to
see a much improved compliance across
gambling operators in this country